So you've created a Python-based open source project, and it's starting to take off.
You're getting contributors, lots of buzz in the podcast space, and more.
But you have that day job working on Java still.
How do you make that transition from popular hobby project to a full-time job?
After all, you're giving away your open source project for free, right?
Well, on this episode, I put together an amazing panel of guests who all have done exactly this.
Turned their project into full-time work and even companies in some cases.
We have Samuel Colvin, Gina Huska, Sebastian Ramirez, Charlie Marsh, Will McGugan, and Eric Hulsher on to share their stories.
This is Talk Python to Me, episode 448, recorded December 7th, 2023.
Welcome to Talk Python to Me, a weekly podcast on Python.
This is your host, Michael Kennedy.
Follow me on Mastodon, where I'm @mkennedy, and follow the podcast using @talkpython, both on fosstodon.org.
Keep up with the show and listen to over seven years of past episodes at talkpython.fm.
We've started streaming most of our episodes live on YouTube.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel over at talkpython.fm/youtube to get notified about upcoming shows and be part of that episode.
This episode is sponsored by BaseDash.
BaseDash uses AI to build a dashboard for your database.
Get a custom admin view in your Postgres, Microsoft SQL Server, MySQL, MariaDB, or Redshift database.
Get started for free at talkpython.fm/BaseDash.
And it's brought to you by Sentry.
Don't let those errors go unnoticed.
Use Sentry.
Get started at talkpython.fm/sentry.
Hello, everyone.
Charlie, Will, Eric, Sebastian, Gina, and Samuel.
What a big group of people we have here today.
An awesome, awesome group.
Thanks for being here, everyone.
It's going to be super fun to have you on the show.
You know, I know there's so many people out there that are dreaming of an open source project
or even working on open source and contributing to it, but it's something they squeeze in the last hour of their day.
And at some point, all of you have made this amazing transition to where there's enough support, there's enough interest in what you all built that becomes your full-time thing, right?
Which is, I know for many out there, living the dream.
So you all are living the dream.
I'm hopefully you feel that way.
But it's going to be really great to kind of just explore your projects, how do you make that transition, and, you know, what you're up to.
So we have Samuel Colvin on from Pydantic, and he has the tightest schedule.
He's squeezing us in on a far-flung trip, a work trip.
So let's go to you first, Samuel.
Just, you know, tell people a bit about who you are and what your project is to get started.
Yeah, I'm Samuel.
I maintain Pydantic, which is a data validation library for Python that uses PyTynx.
So those weird things you've seen after colon and Python that mostly do nothing unless you run mypy or Pyright.
Pydantic basically enforces them.
Almost exactly a year ago, I was sort of working on Pydantic full-time back then, but really spending my own money to do so.
And a big American VC got in touch.
And fast forward, I raised some money and started a company at the beginning of this year.
I hired now 10 people.
And I'm actually, as you mentioned, I'm in Istanbul at the moment with the whole team.
It turns out if you have a team with Americans, Iranians, and Russians, that Istanbul is one of the few places that you can actually meet efficiently.
So, yeah, we're having a really fun week in Istanbul, mostly working together, and then going after dinner, which is where we are at the moment.
I hope that's a good summary.
Absolutely.
And what a cool experience that you get to hang out with all these people talking about your project in Istanbul.
I just had, by the way, I just had...
I mean, just think that the other thing I would add is that one of the best bits of it has been being able to hire friends of mine from open source, people who had, I think, all but two of the people here have contributed to Pydantic before we started the company, which is how I hired the first, I think, six people.
And then a few more.
being able to pay the property.
Yeah, awesome.
I see a lot of people shaking their head out there as well.
Just coincidentally, I recently had Sydney Runkle on Who Works With You, and she's such an inspiration.
That show is not out yet, but has already been done yet through the weird time shifting of podcasting.
So it'll be out before this, but it's not out yet.
So anyway, very, very cool team you got there.
I guess we'll go around the order of the video.
Pretty bunch pictures here.
So Charlie, you're up next.
Quick, quick bit about you.
Hey, so I'm Charlie.
I am the author of Ruff, which is a Python linter code formatter and code transformation tool written in Rust.
I started working on Ruff about a year ago, maybe like October last year.
Similar time frame to Samuel, yeah.
Yeah, and I worked on it full time for a while, similar to Samuel, although probably not for quite as long.
I was working on it full time without any funding.
And then similarly, I started a company around Ruff and really around the vision of trying to build high performance Python tools.
So take some of the things that make Ruff nice to use and popular and well-liked and try to apply those principles to other parts of the Python tool chain.
Yeah, we're a team of six and we're fully remote.
So no two of us live in the same place.
I guess a couple of us live in the same country, but most of us live in different countries.
And we span basically U.S. central time to, I don't know, we have one person in India and one person in Minneapolis.
And that kind of stretches like the full time zones of the team.
That's a good stretch.
That's a good stretch there.
Well, absolutely.
Congratulations on Ruff.
It is really, really taken off.
And I know the guy right below you and this squares, Sebastian, I saw him saying nice things about it with FastAPI and so on.
Yeah, yeah, I know.
Thanks a lot.
It's just funny because I think I was saying before I started recording, I think when I came on Talk Python last time, I think that might have been my first time ever on a podcast.
And it was to talk about Ruff.
And so I was like, oh, wow, people care about what I'm doing.
That's super cool.
And Pydantic and FastAPI were some of the earliest adopters that people had heard of.
So they were like very early on in the life cycle and helped a lot with, you know, getting people to see Ruff and sort of care about Ruff and know that smart people are using it.
That's awesome.
Well, when you visit Talk Python or the course's website or others, it's all Ruff-ified.
I don't know what the adjective of Ruff is, but it's been Ruff.
It's whatever you want to say.
It's amazing.
It's been Ruff-ed up and it works great.
It's really amazing.
That makes the code sound really bad.
But yeah.
True.
Yeah.
That's maybe not the best.
It's like saying it's sick.
Like, oh, that was a sick trick they did.
It means good.
Yeah, that code is rough.
Yeah, that code is rough, man.
All right.
Will, is your code rough?
Who are you?
It's got some rough edges, certainly.
Welcome.
Yeah.
I'm Will.
I'm probably best known for a library called Rich.
And Rich is a library for writing formatted content in Terminal.
You can write tables and progress bars and syntax highlighted code, all sorts of things.
And then that became quite popular in the Python world.
I think there was a need for it.
And two years ago, I founded Textualize, which is a company which builds on Rich to produce a library called Textual, which allows you to build user interfaces inside Terminal.
And these are kind of more like web interfaces and less like Cursus applications.
Yeah, I was just thinking almost like Flexbox.
You can dock stuff to the side and that's part of a UI.
But it's pretty amazing what you've built.
I think it's pushed the Terminal far beyond what many people thought the Terminal should be doing.
It's been very cool.
It's been a process of discovery.
It's kind of strange.
You've got technology that's been around for decades and are still discovering things they can do, which people haven't tried before.
So, yeah, it's been a lot of fun.
And it's been great to work with a small team of developers.
We've got a small core here in Edinburgh, Scotland, and we've got one developer in Portugal.
So, yeah, it's been great.
And I love the reception and I love what people are building with it.
Yeah.
It's so many people are interested in using Rich.
And there's a ton of plugins, right?
There's like Rich Click and there's pytest Rich and all these things like, well, whatever we're doing, it should also have what you've built, you know?
Yeah.
I love to see that.
I love to see the ecosystem building.
Our adjective is richified, which is not as good as possible.
Richified.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yo, that's rich.
My code is rich.
Okay.
Richified.
Got it.
I love it.
We all have adjectives that we've got to put on things.
Yeah.
I'm a big fan of you and your team's work, by the way.
I mean, I'm sure you hear it all the time that you build awesome stuff.
Cheers.
I appreciate it.
Yeah, indeed.
We all are.
Eric, welcome.
You and I are coming in somewhat local here out of Portland, not Istanbul.
I'm actually out in Bend at the moment.
So yeah.
I absolutely love Bend.
Lots of mountains and whatnot.
But yeah, so my background in Eric Holscher, folks probably know me from kind of the Read the Docs ecosystem.
I feel like I've been doing this for a while compared to everyone else here.
The project actually started in 2010, which is kind of amazing.
And then we actually started the company around it in 2014.
So coming up next year, that'll be 10 years.
And so, yeah, and we're all bootstrapped.
So we haven't done any venture capital.
It's all been kind of just built up the open source and then kind of turned it into a company on top of that.
We kind of have a business model of doing paid for private hosting, you know, companies as well as advertising on open source.
And we spun out a kind of a separate business called Ethical Ads that we built kind of to basically make, you know, better advertising on the internet, not doing any of the creepy tracking stuff.
Read the Docs is so critical to the open source space, not just Python, but especially Python.
Yeah.
I mean, so awesome work on that.
And then just, you know, good job on the ad stuff as well.
It's the tendency of the whole ad space is to be super creepy.
And just like, how much can we resell and how much can we buy to mix in to like create these shadow profiles?
And it's not a good social trend.
It's not good for people.
And it's not really necessary, right?
Like if I want to, you know, I've sponsored ads on Read the Docs or had run ads on Read the Docs before.
And we had a Flask course.
And let's just, you know, run that ad on Flask instead of like, let's see if we can track somebody through Instagram over to Facebook.
Who knew, right?
Yeah, exactly.
We call it, yeah, newspaper advertising.
And it's sort of been really cool with the advances of ML.
Like the content targeting has gotten pretty good, right?
So it's definitely a lot easier technically these days to kind of do that content matching.
But yeah, I think in terms of the kind of open source, maybe the way that I'm a little different than other folks here is we're actually running something more akin to a service.
So Read the Docs, all the code is open source, but a lot of the usage is open source projects using our hosted service.
We do obviously ship a lot of code.
Probably our Sphinx theme is probably the most kind of well-known actual software that people are running.
A little bit similar to the folks here, the kind of sidebar on the left.
And yeah, so I think that's kind of the background is, yeah, we have a little bit of everything.
But yeah, it's a little more akin to something like a SaaS app, I would say.
But the code is all open source.
We do get a contribution in that way as well.
Yeah, awesome.
And, you know, it sounds a little similar to what Textualize is working towards as well, hosting.
I mean, it's more hosting people's apps than hosting people's docs, but not terribly different.
Paying for services is a classic open source monetization strategy, right?
Like you have some way to kind of build the monetization on top.
Yeah, it's like what you build is great, but it's kind of hard for me to run.
Could you just do that?
Like, yeah, sure, we can do that.
Sebastian, always good to see you.
Welcome back.
Thank you very much for having me.
Hello, everyone.
I'm Sebastian Ramirez or Tiangelo.
I created this little tool for building web APIs that is called FastAPI.
And it has been growing quite a bit.
People have liked it, fortunately.
And like, yeah, that's it.
I'm probably the only one that hasn't built a company here, I guess.
Okay, baby.
Okay.
There are two of us.
Nice.
I want to hear that.
Okay, so this year I have been able to work full-time on open source because Sequoia Capital, the VC firm, started this open source fellowship.
And I am the first fellow, so I am kind of the test trial of the program.
So I get, you know, just to work full-time on open source.
And that's how I've been able to just, yeah, release that stuff in FastAPI and the ecosystem, like the other libraries.
FastAPI, SQL model, type, and a couple of other things.
But yeah, that's pretty much it.
Yeah, awesome.
Well, FastAPI is definitely the poster child for modern Python on the web.
You know, and Samuel's work, obviously, is central to that as well, right, with Pydantic being such a core element there.
So very awesome.
Yeah, and like, I mean, FastAPI is built on top of like great open source tools and their needs.
So Pydantic does all the data validation, serialization, documentation.
And on the other side, Starlette does all the web parts.
Yeah, it's like, and like, you know, like it's a very close, how do you call it?
Like a close friendship between all the projects.
Pydantic, Starlet, Ubicorn, FastAPI.
Like, you know, like we actually know each, by this point, we actually know each other in person.
Like the current maintainer of Starlette and Ubicorn works for the Pydantic company.
And he's like the top FastAPI expert right now.
But, you know, like it's very nice because helps the dynamism of like the speed of building stuff.
It's great.
Yeah, I imagine a lot of people don't realize the interconnections between these different projects that are at play here.
Yeah, it's definitely super fun.
Absolutely.
And then it's worth saying we in Pydantic use FastAPI as well as contributing to the libraries that build it.
We also use FastAPI for the services that we're building.
So we're like consumers both directly and indirectly of the things that we maintain in open source.
Awesome.
Chat point off and splash is awesome.
It's turtles all the way down, basically.
Exactly.
This portion of Talk Python To Me is brought to you by BaseDash.
BaseDash is the custom admin panel for your database that you don't have to build.
We've all dealt with endless ad hoc requests for data access.
Your support team wants user records, your non-technical co-founder needs to see charts,
or your engineering team needs an easy way to share your SQL queries.
These all sound like relatively simple tasks, but between building an internal tool,
setting up an analytics product, and then switching back and forth between that and your SQL client,
you've lost so much time.
BaseDash gives you that time back.
With BaseDash, you can instantly generate a visual UI for your database.
All you have to do is connect your data source.
It uses AI under the hood to generate the perfect admin panel for your data.
Voila!
Now anyone in your company has access to the data they need.
They're rolling out a ton of new features like the ability to create charts
using only natural language.
You're going to get hours back in your day,
and I promise you won't want to build an internal tool ever again.
Check them out by visiting talkpython.fm/BaseDash.
That's talkpython.fm/BaseDash.
The link is in your podcast player show notes.
BaseDash is free for small teams, so give it a try.
You've got nothing to lose.
Thank you to BaseDash for supporting the podcast.
Gina, also awesome to have you back.
Welcome in.
Very happy to be back.
That's really, really great to be here now, I think, for the second time.
And the third if we call Python Bytes.
So, yeah, my name is Gina Heuske, and I'm probably, yeah,
I don't know if I'm that well-known throughout the Python community,
but I'm quite well-known in the 3D printing community for having created Octoprint,
which is the snappy web interface for U3D printer,
and the server part of that is all written in Python.
And I started a project back in 2012 when I got my first 3D printer
as your regular pet project on the side after hours vacation, blah, blah, blah.
In 2014, I got hired by a 3D printing company to work on it full-time,
and in 2016, that company ran out of money,
and I suddenly found myself with a full-fledged, full-grown open-source project
and no funding whatsoever.
So I tried this whole crowdfunding stuff with Patreon,
and that is pretty much how I've been working ever since.
So I'm self-employed under German law.
I'm a freelancer.
And, yeah, all my income comes from people who just sent me money
for working on Octoprint.
Did you say since 2016?
Since 2016, yeah.
Wow, okay, cool.
So full-time since 2014,
and self-employed and crowdfunded since 2016.
So it's been a while.
That's awesome.
I also went full-time on all my stuff here in 2016,
although it's technically not open-source.
It talks a whole lot about open-source stuff.
So awesome.
It's been a while.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
I'm still surprised it works, to be honest.
I'm waiting every day that it stops working.
And, yeah, actually, this year it came a bit close,
and then I put out a blog post basically along the lines of,
you know, the income is going this,
but the usage numbers are going that,
so something is amiss here and we need to talk.
And then the community rallied and stuff fixed itself again.
So that is pretty amazing.
That's really awesome.
Congratulations.
It's easy for people to just go,
oh, it's free, and there's some people supporting it,
and just kind of assume that things are taken care of.
But, yeah, really good.
Really good.
Yeah, you have a ton of supporters on GitHub sponsors as well, right?
Actually, I've diversified over the years.
In the beginning, it was only Patreon and PayPal,
and then I started adding new payment platforms and options
because people prefer to be able to use the stuff that they know,
and some people don't like Patreon,
some people don't like and don't know GitHub sponsors and stuff,
and so you just give them the options to choose
whatever they feel comfortable with,
and this increases the likelihood that they actually will go through
with throwing something in your head, so to speak.
At least that's my feeling.
I don't know.
I think that GitHub sponsors has been really positive for open source.
I think it's made it pretty easy to just check a box.
They already have your credit card, potentially,
and you just want to give a little support
instead of a one-time PayPal donation here
that you forget about after once and all that.
Before we move on here, there's a funny comment,
nice comment out.
Kanishk says, this group, look at all of you.
You guys are the Avengers of Python open source, right,
which is kind of like the superheroes.
I love it.
It's somewhat actually true, it seems.
Okay.
So the next thing I want to ask is a little bit of an origin story.
Just what projects did you try and they didn't really get traction,
and then how do you think that your project got traction here?
And I know, Samuel, you might vanish any minute,
so you're next.
You're up first on this one.
That's a really interesting.
I've built a number of things in open source.
I started something last week.
I open source on Friday that has got more stars
over the last three days or, I guess, week now.
as the first project I started, ARQ'd,
has over, I think, coming up on six years.
So, I mean, that's front end,
and front end gets a lot more traction
than like queuing an RPC does.
But, yeah, I don't know how,
obviously there were some things I played with back then
that never took off.
But, yeah, it was this, like,
I think having the right time, right place for Titans.
They'd obviously been around in Titans for a long time,
but back in 2017 when I started Pydantic,
their usage was growing really fast.
And I think there were lots of people like me
who found it kind of frustrating
that they were there and didn't do anything.
So, yeah, I think being the right time,
right place was super valuable for me.
And, obviously, like, great projects like FastAPI,
adopting Pydantic, has made a big difference.
But I don't know.
What's weird, if you look at the download chart,
it's like there was a protection point
at the beginning of 2021.
So then we had, like, 5 million downloads a month.
And since then, there's been kind of
almost exactly linear growth
to now 125 million downloads a month.
So something weird happened in 2021,
not after the project started, I don't know.
But, yeah, I think it was right place, right time.
And that frustration was the starting point.
On that note, I'm going to have to rush guys a bit.
It's great to see everyone.
And I'm sure I'll meet you all in a conference soon.
Bye-bye.
Thanks for dropping in.
Good to see you.
Bye-bye.
All right.
Charlie, keep going around the circle here
just so I don't...
Yeah, you know, it's interesting because I,
like, this is...
Ruff is really my first time being a maintainer,
like, publishing open...
Like, I've been a consumer of open source, right,
for my whole career,
but I was never really, I guess,
a creator or a publisher or a maintainer of open source.
You know, around the time that I started working on Ruff,
I was working on, like, a couple different projects.
And they all...
I was kind of trying to figure out what I wanted to do next.
I'd left my job recently.
And Ruff was kind of motivated by
a lot of the experiences I had at my job,
where I was, like, maintaining a large Python code base.
Did you leave your job
with the intent of going to work on Ruff?
Or were you just like, I'm going to leave,
and then I'm going to figure something out.
And you're kind of like, well, what is the process there?
I left my job with the intent of starting a company,
but I did not think it would be Ruff.
And Ruff was, like, this distracting side project
that I was working on while I was, like...
I was working with a friend,
and we were, like, trying to figure out, like,
the Venn diagram of interests,
of, like, what should we...
What are we willing to work on full-time together?
What makes sense, given, like, our interests?
And then, you know, in all my free time,
I was like, I just want to work on developer tools.
And, like, I worked on...
I built Ruff, or I started building Ruff.
I worked on, like...
Yeah, I worked on a lot of different...
Not a lot, but, like, I did...
We were working on a couple of different projects.
I did, like, a sort of CICD thing
where you, like, write Docker files
and, like, CI files in TypeScript,
and they, like, transpile down.
And I was like, oh, I think that has a lot of cool ideas.
I worked on, like...
It was pretty early in a lot of the LLM stuff.
I worked on, like, a code-based-wide refactoring tool
where you, like, give it examples of, like, before and after,
and then it tries to find examples.
It was, like, a co-pilot for your entire code base.
Kind of...
It didn't work that well, like, at scale,
but it was, like, a cool idea.
So I was, like, working on the stuff that was all open source.
Maybe it could have been a timing thing.
Like, maybe today that would be all the business.
Yeah, I mean, it's also, like, an...
Yeah, it's also an effort thing, I guess.
Like, I put a lot more into Ruff.
And it was interesting because I kept viewing Ruff as, like...
You know, it was probably open source at that point,
but I don't think I had launched, like, launched it.
And I kept viewing it as, like...
Like I said, like, a little bit of a distraction.
And my friend was, like...
You know, I think you should really, like, push to, like,
release this because, like, if you think it's, like, interesting,
then, like, other people will probably think it's interesting.
And he was the person that really, like,
motivated me to actually, like, see it through
to doing the release.
And then I did the release and, like, a lot of people
were actually interested in it.
So that kind of gave me, like, the energy to, like,
really start working on it full-time
and just kind of see where it went.
And it was really, like, projects like Pynantic
and, like, Sebastian started, like, commenting on issues and stuff.
And I was like, wow, like, real serious projects
are looking at this, like, crazy tool.
And let me just see.
I'm just going to do whatever it takes
to make it, like, a feasible choice
and just started, like, cranking through, like,
all the issues and all the things that we were missing.
It escalated pretty quickly, I think.
Did it surprise you?
Oh, yes.
Yes.
Absolutely.
I was convinced that I had faced, like, this problem around tooling
as, like, our code base got large in my last company
and that there was an opportunity to, like, build, like,
better, more performant tooling.
I genuinely wasn't sure, like, how widely that message
would resonate with people.
And so, I don't know, it's like a little bit of luck, right?
Like, sometimes you work on great projects
and then, like, they go nowhere
and, like, just no one happens to see it.
And then sometimes you work on a good thing
and, like, it does go somewhere.
And so, there are certain things that are within your control,
certain things that aren't.
I feel like I did a good job of, like, communicating the project
and, like, why it was interesting and why it was exciting.
But I also feel like I got a little bit lucky
that it just, like, gravitated towards the right people
and got attention in the right ways.
Sure.
Also, maybe that Black had existed,
which is a little ironic
because Black kind of solves a real similar problem.
But, like, people were,
okay, we embrace the idea of the thing that Ruff does really well.
You know, you just convince them to use Ruff in that sense.
Yeah.
I mean, we have a little bit,
I mean, it gets back to this.
Like, we have a little bit of, like,
a second mover advantage, right?
Yes, exactly.
There's a lot of existing tools that people use already
and, like, a lot of those practices,
like, the idea of using a format
or the idea of running code mods,
like, the idea of using a linter
and, like, the knowledge of, like,
what kinds of rules are valuable
and, like, what kinds of analysis we can do.
Like, all this stuff existed.
And that was part of the story, really,
was I was, like, these tools are great
and I get a lot of value out of them,
but I want them to be, like, easier and faster.
And so, yeah, there's definitely a strong timing thing.
I think, like, I think Rust, too,
this is maybe, like, a little bit more specific to what we're doing.
But, like, you know, I think, like,
the intersection between Python and Rust has,
or the, I guess, the interoperability between them
and sort of the ecosystem around it has just grown a lot.
I mean, still, I would say, like, pretty early,
but it's, like, matured and grown a lot over the past few years.
And so even just the fact that, like, at my last company,
we started to introduce Rust
and we started to, like, move some of our core systems into Rust
and expose them over PyO3.
Like, the fact that that existed
and the fact that I was, like, exposed to that,
like, that's all just, like, pure chance.
Otherwise, I never would have thought to do this.
Very cool. Well, congrats.
Well-deserved.
We're all doing the, all using Ruff, as we said, is excellent.
Will, Rich is awesome.
How, why do you think it took off?
Did you try stuff before?
What's the story?
I tried a lot of stuff before, before GitHub.
You know, coding has always been my hobby.
You know, I'd do it for work
and I'd come home and work on a hobby project.
And it just seemed natural to want to share it.
Pre-GitHub, I would just put stuff on my blog
and get some feedback from it there.
I quite enjoyed that.
And yeah, I have a number of open source projects.
Pre-Rich had a BB code parsing library.
I had a chess library.
I had a web toolkit.
So yeah, when Rich came along,
it was another hobby project,
something to keep me entertained.
Why is this terminal so boring?
Come on, see what we can do about that.
You know, I'd always use the terminal
and I'd always struggled
when you've got a page of white text
on black background
and you're trying to pick out an IP address from somewhere.
And, you know, I'd always wished,
oh, I wish it would just format it and colorize it for me.
I know this is possible, but it doesn't happen.
So then, yeah, I just, I started it
and it came together quite well.
When I released it, it was like, boom,
the stars just started accumulating.
Got lots of feedback.
It was very exciting.
And I kept building on it.
It was kind of like issue-driven development.
So people would just ask for something.
Oh, that's a good idea.
And go ahead and implement it.
And it grew from there
and it became really large.
I did actually, prior to Rich,
I had a library called PyFileSystem.
And this is kind of like a wrapper to file systems.
So you can have the same interface
for your FTP server as a hard drive
for a zip file, S3 bucket.
And that got some use in the community.
It wasn't enormous.
But that taught me a lot about building open source,
you know, managing feedback issues, et cetera.
So that was a great experience
when I started working on Rich.
And I was very surprised, actually,
how successful it became.
I remember the first time I realized
that this was bigger than just a hobby project
is when someone told me off for violating Semver,
I released a clear, a clear breaking change
because I thought, nobody's using that yet.
But they were.
So the next day I got told off quite appropriately.
And then I thought, okay,
I'll have to take this more seriously.
If people are using this in their day job,
they can't just have someone
who's just like throwing new bits of code
and changing functionality.
They had to treat it like it was an actual my day job.
Yeah, well, everyone on the call here
probably has a little bit of nervousness about like,
if I break this,
there are a lot of people that depend on this thing.
And it's so different.
It just changes so much.
When you were talking about
the issue-driven development thing too,
I just remember that phase of Ruff
where it was like,
anyone who cared all about the project,
all I wanted to do was make them happy.
And I was like, oh, wow,
that seems like a cool idea.
Let's definitely do it.
And I was just like,
it was the point in time
where I could fix the bug,
cut a release the same day,
and then their thing is fixed.
And then it's like, okay, great.
Now we have a relationship.
Thanks for using my thing.
I just think like,
but that's changed so much.
Right?
Because then I went through
the same experiences of like,
I ship a release with a breaking change
that I didn't really document.
A lot of people get upset.
And then you realize,
okay, I actually have some
more responsibility now.
Yeah, these days,
it's more like trying to find the balance
between saying no to stuff
that you then have to end up maintaining
and not like disappointing people too much
because you say no or things like that.
And then trying to keep this whole interaction
with people nice,
even though you don't want to do stuff
that they want you to do
because you know it's better for the project.
This portion of Talk Python To Me
is brought to you by Sentry.
You know Sentry for the air monitoring service,
the one that we use right here at Talk Python.
But this time,
I want to tell you about a new and free workshop.
Heaming the Kraken,
managing a Python monorepo with Sentry.
Join Salma Alam Nayour,
senior developer advocate at Sentry,
and David Winterbottom,
head of engineering at Kraken Technologies,
for an inside look
into how he and his team develop,
deploy and maintain a rapidly evolving
Python monorepo
with over 4 million lines of code
that powers the Kraken utility platform.
In this workshop,
David will share how his department of 500 developers,
who deploy around 200 times a day,
use Sentry to reduce noise,
prioritize issues,
and maintain code quality
without relying on a dedicated Q&A team.
You'll learn how to find and fix
root causes of crashes,
ways to prioritize the most urgent crashes and errors,
and tips to streamline your workflow.
Join them for free on Tuesday,
February 27th, 2024,
at 2 a.m. Pacific time.
Just visit talkpython.fm
slash sentry-monorepo.
That link is in your podcast player show notes.
2 a.m. might be a little early here in the U.S.,
but go ahead and sign up anyway
if you're a U.S. listener,
because I'm sure they'll email you
about a follow-up recording as well.
Thank you to Sentry for supporting this episode.
PRs are like cake or puppies.
If it's a simple bug fix,
that's like cake.
You'd like, thank you.
I enjoyed that cake.
Then move on.
But some PRs are like a puppy.
It's like terrific.
You like puppies,
but you've got to feed them
and clean up after them.
Why am I standing in the rain
with this puppy on like a Friday night?
How do I get here?
Collecting the book is poop.
Yes, exactly.
Sometimes you say thank you,
but I just can't,
I just can't look after another puppy right now.
That's a difficult thing to come to terms
when the project gets a bit more mature.
Because previously,
you're accepting all the puppies,
but then you have to start saying no,
no to puppies.
And Rich definitely got there
because it accumulated.
Do you hate puppies?
Come on,
that's a pretty hard stance.
I'm kind of a cat person,
to be honest with you.
But yeah,
I mean,
you have to say no.
Unacceptable.
Eventually, yeah.
I think this is where plugins
always kind of like
take the center stage, right?
You're like,
just,
oh,
that sounds like a great idea
for you to maintain
external to my library.
That was exactly my approach
to the whole situation.
Yep.
Here's a plugin API.
Have fun.
But also the probability
of some little change
breaking someone's code
and like being considered
a breaking change
grows
as the project grows
in usage.
And like,
you know,
like at some point
it's like almost
any change
will end up
breaking someone
in very unexpected ways
because they are doing
something really,
really weird.
But you know,
like someone is doing it.
So like it becomes
more and more difficult
to know like,
is this a breaking change
or not?
Like no one should be using
this variable here
or this parameter,
but like,
you know,
there's someone out there
doing that.
So I feel defining
what is actually
a breaking change
and what is,
what is this trick
somewhere
gets more difficult
as things grow.
Yeah,
I don't know.
One of the things
I like that the Django
project did
was kind of basically
only things that are
documented are supported.
Basically,
that was kind of
the line they drew
and I thought
that was a pretty good,
pretty good way
to draw it.
But yeah,
you're always,
you know,
that never actually works.
That doesn't make
people happy.
It just gives you
plausible deniability.
Don't yell at me.
It's not my fault.
I think adding a formal
like versioning policy
is one of the best
things that we did
because for a long time
rough was just
we only used patch releases.
So we got to like
zero,
like 285
or something.
And we had basically
no guarantees
about what would
or wouldn't change
like across releases.
And as the project
got more and more popular,
like that started
to cause more and more problems.
And so Zany,
someone on our team,
like when they joined,
one of the first few things
they did was like
create an actual
formal versioning policy
and we added like
preview behavior.
So like you can opt
similar to what block
has kind of opt in
to like breaking
or more experimental changes.
and so now we have
like clear expectations
around what it means
to like bump a minor release,
et cetera, et cetera.
And like that has made
our lives a lot easier,
like actually having
clear expectations
around that
that are communicated
and respected.
But it's the kind of thing
that you just don't think
about at all
until at least I didn't.
Until I checked on figure.
Yeah.
Some people's code
runs things like
FastAPI
or Octoprint
or whatever.
Your stuff
rewrites people's code.
Yeah, but at least
it doesn't run at runtime.
I don't know.
I actually think it's easier.
Yeah.
Indeed.
All right.
I find you talk about
the plugins thing
because like I've actually
very intentionally
taken the opposite approach,
which is we have like
almost no public API
because like the only
public API is the CLI
and like we don't expose
our API in any other way.
And that's because like
we know we're going to change
like everything internally,
like pretty dramatically.
And so we wanted to have
like full control over that
without having to worry
about breaking people's stuff yet.
But it's like it's starting
to become more of a problem
because more and more people
want to use it as a library
in like different ways.
But it's sort of
a counterintuitive way
to like make our lives
easier as maintainers
was like not expose
any public API
apart from the CLI.
Yeah, very interesting.
That's a funny,
funny sort of anecdote.
I'm rewriting a lot
of the documentation
for SQL model
because I want to have examples.
Right now I have examples
that are compatible
with Python 3.7 and above,
but actually 3.6 and above.
But I want to have
also the syntax
for 3.9 and 3.10.
3.10,
you can have like
the unions using
the vertical bar
and these things.
And I want to have examples
for each one of those.
So the approach I did
was to write a script
that will automatically
update each one of the files
by calling rough
as a soup process.
So that's the API.
And then like,
you know,
like I mean,
the process is like
doing all that stuff.
But like, yeah,
it's like another fanboy
of trying to
use it as an API
before it's available.
Yeah,
with lack of an API,
right?
An API will be created.
Exactly.
I've heard this before
as like Hiram's law,
which is like
with a sufficiently
large number of users,
like any implementation detail
become someone
will eventually rely
on an implementation detail.
Like any arbitrary implementation
to someone
is probably relying
on that behavior,
which is basically
the behavior of the program
is the API.
And unfortunately,
they'll find the underscore
functions.
You've tried to dissuade them
from using
and all the things,
you know,
Eric,
what's the origin story
for Read the Docs
and what did you try
and how do you think
it caught on?
Yeah,
so I mean,
this was kind of
way back in the day,
but yeah,
I kind of got started
writing Django plugins,
you know,
apropos to the conversation.
You know,
I was working at
the Lawrence Journal world
where Django came from
and it was kind of
early in my career
and I was just kind of
getting excited
about open source
and blogging
and just basically
built a few of these
kind of testing related
open source projects
and then that was kind of
where I got started
with open source
and then basically
it was the classic
scratch-on-itch thing,
right?
Like it's like
I have a bunch of
open source projects
I want to write documentation.
How do I solve that problem?
And back in the day
that was a much harder
problem to solve,
right?
It was basically just like
build a zip file
and upload it to
packages.python.org
if folks remember that one
or was it packages
or whatever the docs,
there was a docs hosting
on PyPI basically.
And yeah,
basically just wanted to
kind of build
a better version of that
that in the
integrated with GitHub.
I feel like web hooks
were like the cool new thing
back in 2010.
And so that was really
kind of the insight,
right?
It's like let's build
this kind of like
CICD workflow
on top of web hooks
and actually did build
kind of a version of that
the previous year
around kind of like
code quality stuff.
So it actually ran
kind of like a linter
and built a website
on commit
and had a similar
kind of workflow,
right?
Where it like gave you
a grade and did
all this kind of stuff,
which is like 2009.
And yeah,
that didn't really
catch on at all.
But then I think
Read the Docs
just we built it
and then I was using it
for my own projects
and I actually had the need
to kind of maintain it
and keep it updated.
And then I think people
just kind of grew naturally,
you know,
gave some conference talks,
that kind of stuff.
But I think it just
solved a problem
that people had
and that's always going
to be the best way
to grow a thing.
Yeah, absolutely.
Awesome.
What's Read the Docs
written in?
Is it Django?
Yeah, it's all Django
and Python.
Funny coincidence.
I went to college
in Lawrence
at the University of Kansas.
Oh, nice.
I was right there,
right at the heart
of Django,
but I moved off
to grad school
like a couple years
before all that happened.
So I missed,
missed the excitement.
I grew up in Virginia
and everyone was like,
you're going to Kansas?
You graduated school?
Like, how are you
going there?
Like, what?
Everybody thought
it was the weirdest decision,
but yeah,
like I really do think,
you know,
ending up in that Python
and Django ecosystem
has been pretty transformative
to my life.
So, you know,
worked out.
Lawrence is a pretty cool
little town, actually,
of all the places.
Yeah.
Sebastian,
how did you come about
this crazy idea
to put types
into our web apps?
You know,
Python,
that's dynamic.
It doesn't have types.
What are you doing?
Yeah, I don't know.
It's so crazy.
It's so fun to see
it said Michael Larson
in the chat,
like,
they maintain
our URL E3
and the Python
security developer
in Resilience
just, like,
chatting along with us.
Like,
he probably has had
to deal with
so much stuff
as us.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
So, like,
some of the first things
that I did in open source
were actually
Docker images
for deploying Flask
because I was working
with Flask
and deploying Flask
was difficult
and I needed to be able
to combine
Nginx with UWSGI
and, like,
a bunch of things
they all had
their own
custom configuration files
and it was, you know,
like, so difficult.
I didn't like doing that
and then I just had
to study how to do
that stuff
and then after
going through all that
I wanted to save
everyone else's time
doing that.
So, we're like,
well,
let's just put a Docker image
with this
and a lot of documentation
of how this Docker image
works
and how you can use it
with some sensible defaults.
So, you know,
it was just like
a weird contraption
that was it
but it actually grew
and, like,
got, like,
a few stars,
like,
a bunch of stars.
For me,
it was a lot,
you know,
like,
100 stars.
Oh, my gosh,
I have an open source
developer.
And then, like,
at some point
it had, like,
a thousand stars
or something like that.
I was so happy about that.
And at some point
it was kind of
the de facto standard
for doing
Flask,
Docker,
Flask-indocker.
that was the first thing
that I did.
I ended up
with FastAPI.
I was avoiding
building FastAPI
for a long while
and I was trying
all the other frameworks
and all the other tools.
I was convinced
that there was something
that would do
the things that I wanted.
I just had to find it.
And as I was trying
different frameworks,
also in different languages,
I was extending
the list of things
that I wanted to have
and also the list
of things that I wanted
not to have.
For example,
I didn't want to...
That takes you
farther and farther away
from any framework
so you're out.
having one that would
tickle the boxes.
So it was like,
ah.
But then I realized
I really like this thing
of having types
because you get out
of completion
and inline errors
and this is so cool.
It's so cool
to be able to have this.
I want to have this in Python
and then Python
added type annotations
and it was like,
this is great.
How do I use them?
There's no way
to use them
with the current frameworks.
So at some point
I actually found
the right framework.
It was called API Star
by the same author
of Django REST framework.
It was just missing
some authentication stuff.
I said like,
okay,
I'm going to contribute
to the other stuff.
When I was about
to jump into the code,
he said,
I have to deprecate this.
I will go focus
full on Starlet.
And then he went
to build Starlet.
This is Tom Christie,
which is super prolific
and an amazing
open source person
in general.
And then at that point
is when I said like,
ah,
just have to try it.
Let's just do it.
So I'm just going to try
to build something
that will be
kind of a spiritual successor
to API Star
built on top of Starlet.
So I was,
you know,
like I was actually
narrating all the learnings
from Flask,
Django,
Django REST framework
and all the ecosystem
and just like bringing
all those ideas together.
At least that was my intention.
And then I wanted
to have a bit
of better type annotations.
So I saw that
Pydantic was using
standard type annotation.
So people wouldn't
have to learn this
like,
you know,
from FastAPI
for special string
or something like that.
Just instead of that,
just use pure string.
So I wanted to have
something based on standards
like OpenAPI,
JSON schema
and all that stuff
and based on standard Python
and to have like
the simplest syntax possible
and to,
you know,
like give the best
developer experience possible
while,
you know,
like not adding
like any additional steps
for developers
to build something
that by default
will have all the best practices
built in.
That was the intention.
And I was just like
trying to solve it
for the things
that I was working on.
I was supposed to be doing
AI and machine learning
and stuff,
but like I had to stop
for a bit to solve APIs.
I got stuck in APIs.
That's how I ended up
with FastAPI.
Oh,
I think you made
a pretty decent choice.
It seems like FastAPI
is doing all right.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I just saw you.
It's much better
than what I ever had expected.
Yeah,
I know.
Congratulations.
Well,
it's also deserved,
but I also just saw
an X,
I don't know,
a post on X Twitter,
whatever you,
however you,
addressed these things,
where you said
you showed a graph
where the number
of GitHub stars
for FastAPI
just passed Flask.
And,
you know,
I have a lot of respect
for Flask
and the Palette team
and David Lord
and all those folks,
but,
you know,
awesome,
awesome that your stuff
has taken off so much.
That's really cool.
It's super cool.
It's amazing.
And,
you know,
like Flask was
one of the big inspirations
for FastAPI,
and I've been able
to be at this point.
It's crazy.
Like,
yeah,
I still can't get over it.
Yeah,
super cool.
super cool to be able
to build all this
and to keep building
more stuff.
So,
yeah,
super nice.
one final comment
before we move on
to Octoprint.
But,
one of the things
I kind of see
you doing in the world
is you're like
the combiner.
You're like,
oh,
we've got this cool stuff
with Pydantic
and Starlet,
and how can we combine it
in this way
to make this,
you know,
and Swagger.
And,
like,
similarly with SQL model,
you're like,
well,
Pydantic is cool,
but SQLAlchemy
is kind of cool,
but it could be more
or better,
you know,
like,
it could be better,
right?
So,
anyway,
good job.
Yeah,
and also,
like,
Typer,
that is the library
for building
command line applications.
It just click
with the type annotations,
the same ideas
from Pydantic,
and now with,
you know,
like,
integrated building
support for reach.
So,
like,
also,
picking Will's work,
trying just to put
a bunch of things together.
I'm just,
you know,
like,
I'm just making cocktails
everywhere.
Yes,
exactly.
It's more than that,
but there is a lot of value
in combining things
in a smart way
and accessible way.
Yeah,
awesome.
All right,
Gina,
you told us a little bit
about the origin story,
but like,
what did you try before?
And then I have
a follow-up question
that I think is unique
to your project.
I wouldn't necessarily say
that I tried anything before
because the whole thing
was completely unintentional.
I basically bought myself
a 3D printer
in late 2012.
I wanted to be able
to put it in my spare bathroom
and monitor it from afar
because back then
this thing was tying up
my PC.
You had to constantly
keep it connected
so it could operate
and that for hours
and hours
and it made noises
and it produced fumes
and I just wanted it
out of my office
and to be able
to play games
on my PC again
instead of having it
basically communicate
constantly with a 3D printer.
And so I bought myself
a Raspberry Pi
and I was looking online
for something
to be able to just
put on this Pi
and attach to the printer
and throw a Wi-Fi dongle in
because back then
the Pi didn't have Wi-Fi
built in
and throw that
in the spare bathroom
but there wasn't anything.
So over the course
of my Christmas break
in 2012
I sat down
and changed that
and this is basically
the origin story
of Octoprint.
I just wanted to
scratch my own itch.
I wanted to put my printer
in my spare bathroom.
This is all.
And apparently
a lot of people
had the same problem
because I just
you know
like how we
like to do these things.
We build something
that we think
might be interesting.
We throw it up
on GitHub
and go just like here
go nuts
enjoy
have fun with that
and I suddenly
started getting emails
from all around the world
like hey
I have this
in this printer
can you also
make it work with that
and so this escalated
and I went like
oh someone is using it
of course I'm going
to add this support
and of course
I'm going to add
this feature
and it just grew
and grew and grew
and grew
and apparently
I just hit a nerve
so this was utterly unplanned
this was never
my intention at all
and I just wanted
to solve my own problem
and have continued
to solve my own problems
and the problems
of other people
ever since.
Before Octoprint
I actually was also
quite active
in a little project
called DocuViki
where I was developing
some plugins for that
and I even did
open source
before I knew
what open source was
with some PHP scripts
when I was 18 or so
that I threw up
on my website
but yeah Octoprint
was like
it took over my life
it just was an accident
a happy little accident
maybe.
How did you decide
okay this is a job
for me
rather than
just a thing
you worked on?
The thing is
by mid-2030
I went to
80% on my
regular day job
I used to be a
software architect
slash consultant
with big corporation
Java World
all the enterprise stuff
and to be able
to dedicate
one day per week
fully to Octoprint
plus of course
the weekends
and the after hours
and the vacations
and all of that
and that still
didn't suffice
anymore by 2014
and I noticed
that it was
impacting my health
it was impacting
my relationships
and that was
actually
quite perfect timing
really when
this company
that hired me
initially
approached me
and said
hey do you want
to maybe fly out
to us
and we'll chat
and if you like
all of that
what we have to propose
then we can
just do that
and this is
how it then
continued to go
from 2014
until 2016
and yeah
it was never
my intention
to become
self-employed
I'm a quite
risk-averse person
actually
so when this
point came
where I was like
okay either
I find a way
to keep funding
this or I have
to really drop it
because it was
way too big
by then to be
kept as a pet
project without
being utterly
utterly unhealthy
yeah I decided
to jump into
the cold water
and have been
trying to keep up
at the surface
ever since
basically
so yeah
all of that
really completely
unplanned
cool what an
adventure
indeed yeah
and the good
thing is even
if people don't
understand what
open source is
or what code is
I always have
quite a topic
at parties
so that is fun
because yeah
like people give
you money
for something
they can get
for free
what
exactly
yeah
if you're not
familiar with
open source
then it definitely
is a weird
it was tricky
to find a text
consultant
who understands
the concept
so
yeah I can
imagine
that's interesting
I'm sure
all right
I was very
recently I was like
what do you do
what is your
day
oh I'm a
software developer
so you work
for a company
not really
what is it
that you build
well I build
a platform that
is free
for others to
use
and who's paying
you
a company
that pays
money to
companies
to build
so you're
building a
company
no
it's actually
you know
like it was
a long
conversation
they got bored
and later
this doesn't
make any sense
yeah
I've just
taken to say
I'm a software
developer
and I work
with 3D
printers
and then people
usually stop
asking questions
because 3D
printers are
this mysterious
thing that no one
understands
anyhow
usually at least
and then yeah
unless they say
oh 3D printers
and then I say
yeah do you know
3D printers
and they go
yeah yeah
I have one
and then I can say
oh do you know
Octoprint
yes
oh yeah I made
that and then
oh yeah
it's tricky to explain
to people
I'm sometimes
not even sure
my parents
understand
what I do
so
I'm sure
that my parents
don't understand
what I do
that's okay
I'm sure
they're still
proud of you
anyway
it's fine
yeah
my definitely
are proud of you
I would like to
just maybe
getting a little
short on time
you're coming up
to the end
of our Avengers
meeting
let's close it out
with this
go around
one more time
let y'all
or maybe just
as a group
kind of chime
in on this
speaking to the
people out there
listening
who want to
start an open
source project
or want to
contribute to
open source
or somehow
kind of get
involved in
similar ways
what would you
do different
if you started
now
many of you
have been working
on this
for a long
time
you've had
a lot
of experience
like if
somebody said
well
the world
is
somehow
the memory
has been
erased
from
the fact
that
rough
or rich
or octafrid
or whatever
existed
to start over
what would you
do
different
or the same
I would use
FastAPI
yay
good use
of a time
machine
there
everybody
I've had
multiple
conversations
over the years
where people
are like
why don't
you use
this library
I'm like
oh it
didn't
exist
exactly
yeah
this is the
problem
exactly
when you
actually have
a plug-in
system
then swapping
out
stuff like
that can
become
very tricky
absolutely
when I get
asked what
to work
on what
to study
what to
focus
how to
get into
open source
or like
almost any
of those
questions
I always
say that
the main
advice I
give is just
to focus
on a problem
that is
important to
you
more than
you know
like
innovation
market
disruption
or war
whatever
just like
focus on
a problem
that is
actually
important
to you
hopefully
that is
important
to others
as well
and if
it's not
a problem
that affects
you
directly
hopefully
it affects
someone
that is
very close
to you
so you
can get
like a
very
tight
feedback
loop
of what
you are
building
and then
try to
solve it
and then
use that
as the
guide
of
what to
do
learn
what to
focus
on
what to
do
in many
cases
it's just
learning a
framework
that
is already
there
you know
like
why would
I go
and build
a system
to control
3D printers
instead of
just like
learning how
to use
auto print
in many
cases
solving the
problem
is just
like
using
the tool
that is
already
there
but then
in some
cases
you end up
figuring out
that there's
no tool
and you just
have to
build it
there's
actually
no
lint there
and formatter
that can be
super fast
so you can
run it
every time
you just
hit save
so then
you just
have to
build it
in Rust
and create
rough
or like
you know
like
there's always
like this
thing that
you are trying
to solve
that is just
not solved
there yet
and that
is what
gives you
the best
value
and the
best
outcome
in many
cases
it can be
just like
you know
contributing
to another
open source
project
or
building
something
new
but the
thing is
like
for me
it's just
like
focusing
on a
problem
that is
important
what
has
worked
for me
at least
good advice
I would
add to
that
you
really
shouldn't
try to
you need
to be
really
passionate
about
the
thing
as
well
right
it
needs
to be
something
that
is
really
something
you're
into
something
that
will
you
want
to
spend
a lot
of
time
on
that
is
actually
not
your
working
hours
and such
because
otherwise
the whole
jog
until
this
becomes
anything
viable
big
enough
to
support
you
in
any
kind
of
way
even
if
it's
just
being
able
to
drink
a
coffee
per
week
or
something
that
will
be
a
quiet
long
slog
and
a lot
of
work
and
a lot
of
blood
and
sweat
tears
and
so
you
really
need
to
be
into
this
so
that
you
want
to
do
that
if
you
are
just
in
that
for
the
end
goal
of
I
don't
know
becoming
rich
through
open
source
which
by the
way
will
probably
not
work
only
will
I
go
rich
then
this
will
not
work
out
you
need
to
focus
on
the
path
to
the
goal
a lot
of
people
try
to
reach
for
the
end
goal
before
they
are
willing
to
walk
the
path
I
happen
to
be
in
the
GitHub
star
program
and
I've
had
a lot
of
people
become
a
GitHub
star
and
that
is
the
wrong
question
to
ask
how do
you
become
an
open
source
maintainer
of a
popular
project
you
just
have
to
do
whatever
you
are
interested
in
you
have
to
do
work
and
you
have
to
be
passionate
about
your
work
and
then
maybe
if
you
hit
the
right
nerve
then
that
will
happen
and
maybe
it
won't
I
think
it's
very
interesting
that
none
of
us
had
a
career
path
to
where
we
are
now
we
didn't
set
out
to
be
where
we
are
now
it
just
feels
like
we
followed
our
intuition
and
it
worked
out
which
means
it's
very
difficult
when
someone
asks
me
how
do
you
become
an
open
source
developer
how
do
you
start
a
company
I'm
not
quite
sure
I can
tell
you
my
path
to
there
but
it's
very hard
for me
to
articulate
someone
else
how
to
get
there
I
think
there's
a lot
of luck
involved
as well
right
it's
like
you
have
to
do
all
this
stuff
and
roll
this
dice
if
it
gets
successful
there's
an
element
of
luck
but
it's
kind
of
luck
you
make
for
yourself
and
it
might
take
you
to
somewhere
else
or
it
might
not
but
as long
as
you're
passionate
about
it
and
you
enjoy
it
then
great
things
will
happen
I
think
also
Will
and
Charlie
you
both
took
some
specific
time
on
your
own
money
to
really
level
up
what
you're
working
on
which
is
pretty
brave
not
a lot
of
people
would
say
I'm
just
going
to
spend
my
savings
to
work
on
this
project
make
it
go
so
you've
earned
some
of
that
through
taking
that
chance
and
putting
that
time
and
effort
I
think
for me
that
didn't
last
long
because
I'm
after
months
I
was
living
on
GitHub
sponsorship
VCs
came
along
and then
there
was
cash
everything
changed
and
you
had
to
learn
a
whole
new
set
of
skills
I'm
sure
I
do
feel
lucky
that
like
I
said
this
is
my
first
time
being
a
maintainer
and
it
was
very
clear
to
me
quickly
that
for
Ruff
to
have
the
pace
of
development
and
the
scope
that
full
time
thing
and
that
was
pretty
obvious
to me
quickly
and
I
have
a
lot
of
respect
for
people
who
have
been
maintainers
for
longer
periods
of
time
and
in
a
way
where
it's
not
their
full
time
job
or
they
have
side
I
have
been
in
that
position
but
it's
already
clear
to
me
that
takes
a
lot
of
dedication
and
commitment
so
I
feel
very
lucky
that
I
get
to
work
on
open
source
full
time
I
know
it's
not
all
entirely
luck
right
like
you
increase
your
luck
surface
area
and
opportunities
come
your
way
but
I
do
think
it's
a
fortunate
position
that
these
kinds
of
opportunities
do
exist
because
maintaining
popular
stuff
is
a lot
there are
privileges
that
come
with
it
100%
but
it's
a lot
of
work
and a lot
of
stress
and a lot
of
responsibility
and you
don't
necessarily
have to
start
your
own
right
away
I
didn't
have
gray
hair
before
this
you
don't
have to
start
your
own
either
you
could
contribute
to a
really
popular
one
and
get
into
the
scene
and
you
know
like
Eric
that
sounds
a little
bit
like
your
story
like
you
were
in
the
Django
scene
and
then
spun
off
from
that
what
you
are
doing
right
yeah
definitely
and
you know
part
of an
open
source
community
and
definitely
going to
PyCon
and just
being
surrounded
by
those
people
because
that
was
always
the
it's
very
lonely
work
just
to
have
an
inbox
of
github
issues
and
no
inbox
thank
you
know
and
like
going
to
conferences
and that
kind
of
stuff
was
really
where
you
feel
the
appreciation
and
you
really
kind
of
actually
feel
the
value
that
you're
providing
as well
as
just
the
stress
of
the
things
you're
breaking
so
absolutely
the
conferences
are great
to really
feel the
appreciation
rather than
just
the
request
they'll
say
thank you
and then
they'll
give you
a bug
report
but at
least
the
thank
you
I'm
talking
to
you
there
is
this
can
I
just
show
you
this
an
interesting
observation
for me
a year
ago
I
didn't
know
anyone
in
Python
open
source
at all
I was
a user
of Python
in my
day job
every
day
but I
was not
interacting
with Python
in a
year
now
like
Sebastian
we've
interacted
a bunch
there's
a lot
of
people
that
I've
come
to
know
and
think
of
as
friends
so
I
think
especially
if
you're
interested
in
getting
involved
and
putting
in
work
I
really
don't
think
there
are
significant
barriers
and
you get
out of
it
what
think
I've
been
very
impressed
with
just
how
welcoming
and
friendly
the
community
has been
especially
other
maintainers
yeah
absolutely
talk to a lot
of people
who show up
at PyCon
and they're
like I was
really nervous
to come
here
or I feel
like it
didn't
fit in
and they're
you know
just had
such a
great
experience
and I
said well
did you
feel
like
that was
my
first
PyCon
this
year
I'd
never
been
to a
fight
on
conference
and so
I was
like
we did
up at
such
an
amazing
party
that's
true
that was
interesting
all right
guys
well I
think we
are
pretty
much
out
of
time
anyone
want to
have
some
final
thoughts
for
listeners
before
we
wrap
it
up
go
and
build
some
cool
stuff
who's
brave
enough
how
can
maintain
it
today
I
think
give
cake
not
puppies
let's
leave
it
with
that
huh
all right
give
cake
not
puppies
and be
really
careful
before you
start a
popular
source
project
it
might
take
over
your
life
if
you
want
this
great
but
if
not
then
yeah
careful
what
you
wish
for
you
might
get
it
exactly
Gina
Sebastian
Eric
Will
Charlie
thank you
all for
being
on the
show
this
has
been
a
a ton
of
fun
thank
you
very
much
for
having
us
a
pleasure
and
honor
to
be
with
these
amazing
people
thank
you
for
the
invitation
I
agree
honestly
I
had a
blast
just
hearing
everyone's
stories
because
I
hadn't
heard
any
of
this
before
so
thanks
to
everyone
else
and
thanks
Michael
yeah
you
bet
bye
this
has
been
another
episode
of
talk
python
to
me
thank you
to
our
sponsors
be sure
to
check
out
what
they're
offering
it
really
helps
support
the
show
this
episode
is
sponsored
by
base
dash
uses
AI
to
build
a
dashboard
for
your
database
get
a
custom
admin
view
in
your
postgres
Microsoft
SQL
server
my
SQL
Maria
DB
or
Redshift
database
get
started
for free
at
talkpython.fm
slash
base
dash
take
some
stress
out of
your
life
get
notified
immediately
about
errors
and
performance
issues
in your
web
or mobile
applications
with
Sentry
just
visit
talkpython.fm
slash
Sentry
and get
started
for free
and be
sure to
use the
promo
code
talkpython
all one
word
want to
level up
your
python
we have
one of
the largest
catalogs
of python
video courses
over at
talkpython
our content
ranges from
true beginners
to deeply
advanced topics
like memory
and async
and best of
all there's
not a
subscription
in sight
check it
out for
yourself
at
training.talkpython.fm
be sure to
subscribe to
the show
open your
favorite podcast
app and
search for
python
we should
be right
at the
top
you can
also find
the
iTunes feed
at
slash
iTunes
the
Google
play
feed
at
slash
play
and the
direct
RSS feed
at
slash
RSS
on
talkpython.fm
we're live
streaming most of our
recordings these days
if you want to be part of the show and have your comments featured on the air
be sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel at talkpython.fm slash
YouTube
this is your host Michael Kennedy
thanks so much for listening I really appreciate it now get out there and write some Python
code
Music